دانت وزاره الخارجيه السودانيه هجوما
وصفتها بمليشيا الدعم السريع المتمرده على
مقر السفاره القطريه بالخرطوم والعبث
بمحتوياتها وسرقه المقتنيات دون مراعاه
للاعراف والقوانين الدوليه المعنيه بحمايه
الدبلوماسيين ومقاري البعثات الدبلوماسيه
وادعت الخارجيه السودانيه المجتمع الدوليه
الى ادانه هذا السلوك والى اعتبار الدعم
السريع منظمه ارهابيه والى تحميلها
المسؤوليه القانونيه والاخلاقيه حسب وصفها
معنى هنا في الاستوديو محلل الشؤون
السياسيه والعسكريه السودانيه اسامه
عيدروس استاذ اسامه اهلا وسهلا بك الحرب
يعني تجاوزت الشهر وما زالت مستمره
ماذا في ابرز ما يلفت النظر في تطورات هذه
الحرب هل هنالك تطور كبير حدث هذا هذه
الايام او الاسابيع السته بالنسبه لي انا
عندما اتابع هذه الحرب اتابع المؤشرات
العامه للحرب المؤشرات العامه للحرب تقول
انه الدعم السريع انتشر في مساحات واسعه
في ولايه الخرطوم وبدا يتحدث عن سيطرته
عليها في الوقت الذي فقط كل معسكراته
الثابته
حاول ان ان يهجم على اهداف كبيره مثل
القياده العامه وفشل وتوسعت دائره التامين
حول القياده العامه في الفتره الماضيه بدا
يهاجم اهداف عسكريه رخوه من اجل احراز
يعني ضجه اع حول نشاطه فهاجم يعني حتى فرع
الرياض العسكريه سلاح الاسلحه سلاح
الاشاره وفشل فيها كلها مع فقدانه للقياده
والسيطره اصبحت هذه القوات مشتته وموزعه
في كل الخرطوم لكن فقدت التوجه نحو اي هدف
عسكري يعني اصبح ليس لها هدف عسكري واضح
ومفهوم مجرد قوات موجوده ومنتشره في
الخرطوم ما هي خطوتها التاليه ما الذي
تريد ان تفعله هذا غير معلوم الشيء الثاني
يعني زادت من وتيره انتهاكاتها يعني بعد
احتلال المستشفيات ثم احتلال المرافق
العامه الخدميه وذلك حتى تؤمن نفسها من
الطيران انتقلت الى مهاجمه البعثات
الدبلوماسيه حتى الان خمس بئسات دبلوماسيه
في الخرطوم اصدرت بيانات
انها تم مهاجمتها وتم الاعتداء عليها كذلك
هنالك يعني عمل كبير وواسع في اختطاف
المدنيين
واستخدامهم في يعني في الدعايه الاعلاميه
لقوات الدعم السريع
الغريب في الامر انه يصل الامر الى
البعثات الدبلوماسيه والمهاجم معروف
ومعلوم لكن ليس هنالك تحرك دولي من اجل
ادانه او ايقاف هذه يعني هل المجتمع
الدولي في البدايه كان منقسم جدا حول هذه
الحرب
وتحرك في مجلس الامن من بريطانيا
والولايات المتحده الامريكيه كان يعني
يحاول ان يصل بالامر الى البنده السابع
والتدخل في السودان لكن سرعان ما تغير
الامر
فجاه هذه الفظائع الكبيره التي تسببت فيها
قوات الدعم السريع بالاضافه الى الانكسار
العسكري واختفاء الهدف السياسي من وراء
هذه الحرب يعني الذين كانوا يقفون من
ورايا هذه الحرب يعني هبطت عزيمتهم
وتراجعوا الى الوراء الجميع يتحدث عن
طرفين في هذه الحرب ولم يبدو طوارئ
الاسابيع الماضيه ان هنالك طرفا قد حسم
هذه المعركه الان الان يتحرك الدعم السريع
يعني بحثا عن وقف لاطلاق النار في جبى وفي
يوغندا والواقع انه فوتوا فرصه المفاوضات
الاولى في جده اذا كانوا جادين في الوصول
الى وقف اطلاق نار كان يمكن ان يصدر ذلك
مع اتفاق المبادئ الاول لكن اتفاق المبادئ
ارجع قضيه ايقاف وقف اطلاق النار الى
مفاوضات لاحقه لانه كل القنوات
الاعلاميه وكل يعني السفارات ورجال الدوله
عندما يتحدثون عن حرب السودان يتحدثون
عنها وكانها حرب لا يمكن حسمها عسكريه
الان تكشف انهزام الدعم السريع وعدم قدرته
على تحقيق لا نصر سياسي ولا نصر عسكري كل
اهدافه العسكريه فشل في اليها
الجيش طبعا اذا حسبنا انه هذه الحرب
ابتدات قبل شهر في كل ولايات السودان مع
تمركز الدعم السريع في 35 معسكر داخل
المراكز الحيويه للعاصمه الخرطوم سنجد انه
هذا الجيش طبق استراتيجيه واسعه جدا نقل
بها الحرب يعني من هذا المكان الواسع مع
تدميره لكل خطوط الامداد لحركه التمرد
والان يقوم بالحفاظ يعني
على قواعد الاشتباك في الحرب للحفاظ على
حياه المدنيين وتسير يعني الان هنالك شعور
ان الجيش يعرف ما الذي يفعله في الخرطوم
وسيصل بهذه في هذه الحرب الى نهايتها
نشكرك شكرا جزيلا محلل الشونه السياسيه
والعسكريه السودانيه ضيفنا في الاستوديو
اسامه عيدروس شكرا لك شكرا